i'm not a hardcore capitalist or a
socialist i think that the the idea that
it's that black and white
is is a lie it's just a lie we've been
sold right like socialist programs
make a ton of sense they add a
tremendous amount of value to this
country make the country as great as it
is
um and i think a lot of capitalist
values make a ton of sense as well but
there's there's a place where regulation
is
essential it's essential and the things
like amazon and jeff bezos
like those are people being paid with
their paid like there's no one that can
look at that and think about an employee
taking a piss
in a bottle on the on the floor because
they can't you know essentially
amazon is a logistics company and they
can't take a five minute break to go do
what they need to do
when if you're you know well educated
and you have the privilege to make that
happen you essentially end up working a
four hour or five dollar workday
maybe and you can do it yeah yeah
no one sees that doesn't think it's
disgusting in some way right
well some people do there are
libertarians who say uh
if that is what the market is offering
and people don't like it
then they should either go and look for
a different job which will
raise the wage that needs to be paid or
it'll force amazon to allow five-minute
breaks or whatever
that there are libertarians who actually
would defend that but it's
you know it's it's it's sort of a
fantasy world i think more relevant
is um you know my view is a sort of
northern european
socially democratic view which is we
want markets
and we want private industry and
i am very comfortable with markets and
profit
directing the activity of many types of
companies
i don't need the government making all
of the mobile phones i think
it's fine that you know apple can make a
phone and samsung and lg and
i'm fine directing resources um in that
way
but there are certain things that should
be taken out of that mechanism
healthcare would be one of them
education would be one of them
you know i think the postal service is a
great service that i'm perfectly fine
with it not being profitable that's sort
of my
perspective which is i'm okay with
markets directing resource allocation
except when it really doesn't make sense
and we should figure out a different
system
and the idea that that that that
regulation
uh kneecaps that that industry or that
market
is incredibly naive to me i think that
those that markets are so powerful and
so robust that
regulation is is necessary in
like minimum wage in this is another
libertarian fantasy that minimum wage is
a is
is a violation of our rights or
something it it
that's necessary because the funny thing
is that
that's what trust me on about
libertarians they love that like
competition is the
is the bedrock of their whole thing if
you have if you have free markets and
you have competition and competition
runs essentially their whole system it
is the check and balance within the with
that system
yeah it's usually it's that and the this
sort of like non-aggression principle
that they that they cite
exactly but companies don't want to
compete
so as soon as they can purchase
influence and minimize competition
they're going to do that
it's in it's in the nature of an of an
industry to not want to compete
it's in the nature of a human being did
not want to compete if you don't have to
compete
so so it's it's against the nature of an
industry
to follow the rules of libertarianism
that's one thing that i've never really
been able to wrap my head around is how
can you not
see that very glaring gap in your logic
yeah it certainly concentrates and
creates monopolistic
uh industries and and uh circumstances
that that's
very much true um but again sort of
going back to what we said earlier the
other area where it fails is once some
of these entities get so big
there really isn't anything but the
power of government to do the regulation
yeah and i think that i'm curious what
your thoughts are on this
it feels that campaign finance reform is
the most necessary thing that we can
change
like the amount of influence that
industry has on policy making
to me is on its face just completely
unfair
and i don't know i haven't seen anybody
run on that outside of maybe a
libertarian candidate here or there i
think bernie talked about it in 2016
more than 2020
is there is there any is that does that
make sense at the end of the day does
that make sense that campaign finance
reform
would make a profound shift in
everything from health care to industry
and regulation
yeah i mean i think really like the
three pillars
that like if you care about education
versus if you care about gun rights
versus if you care whatever issue you
care about
really what we need to be looking at is
campaign finance reform
changing the first-past-the-post voting
system to better enable third parties
to participate and number three
dealing with climate change because if a
city is under water it's hard for its
residents to be advocating for anything
so that
if you said what are the kind of like
the top three things that
across all political issues need to be
dealt with
i would say it's those three yeah
absolutely and by and and i would say
also four is healthcare because
if you're sick and you can't access
healthcare you also can't be an activist
for education or gun rights or whatever
you want so probably those are the four